ce qui m'a aussi beaucoup frappé dans la
mission que j'ai fait récemment c'est
qu'un certain nombre de nos partenaires
disons historiques ou traditionnels dans
les pays du Maghreb aujourd'hui et
maintenu les ministres ont tenu les
propos m'expliquant que le Maghreb de
grands-papa ou de papa en tout c'était
terminé que il n'était pas question de
donner par un temps mouvement naturel ou
un penchant naturel là la préférence a
des alliances avec l'Europe ou avec la
France les votes à l'occasion de la
guerre en Ukraine l'ont dur amplement
démontré et que si tel ou tel pays du
Maghreb où l'on pensait être en
cousinage ou en très grande proximité en
tout cas
estimait que les accords d'Abraham lui
permettait d'avoir un meilleur une
opportunité avec Israël ou avec la Chine
ou avec la Russie et bien c'est sur la
base une contractualisation libre qu'il
allait choisir c'est sa tactique ou ses
stratégies alors tout ça bien sûr créer
une complexité
dans le décryptage la lecture des
relations internationales dont je vous
réitère aussi qu'elles ont des
incidences sur la scène sur les scènes
nationales
particulièrement difficile à penser
puisque le tout l'appareil conceptuel
qui a été construit pour penser les
relations internationales depuis la fin
de la Seconde Guerre mondiale et jusqu'à
au moment où la chute du mur de Berlin
avait opposé d'un côté le clash des
civilisations à la fin de l'histoire
tout pas aujourd'hui semble très en deçà
pour nous permettre de penser les
conflits auxquels nous sommes confrontés